Speaker 1: Major breaking news from
within the world of the Democratic Party.
Senator Bernie Sanders, according to aides, has
not ruled out running for president again in 2024
if Joe Biden doesn't run. There
is a very interesting article
in The Washington Post. Senator Bernie Sanders
is open to running for president in 2024 if
Biden declines to seek reelection, according to a
campaign memo. A top political adviser distributed
to allies on Wednesdays on Wednesday and shared
with The Washington Post quote In the event of
an open 2024 Democratic primary, Senator Sanders
has not ruled out another run for president, so we
advise that you answer any questions about 2024.
With that in mind, this is a memo from Faz Shakir,
Close Sanders adviser who managed his campaign
in 2020. The memo was shared by a person with
direct knowledge of its contents on the condition
of anonymity because it was not released publicly
and confirmed by a second person with direct
knowledge of the contents. So many in my audience
have been clamoring, saying twenty twenty
four will finally be the time for Bernie.
Everybody will realize that it was a mistake
in 2016 for him not to be the nominee,
and it was a mistake in 2020 for him to not
be the nominee and or it was stolen from
him. And 24 is when Bernie will sail to the
nomination and then sail to the presidency.
I think that this is a really bad idea. I know
many in my audience will be furious with me.
I like Bernie. I supported Bernie in
2016. I supported Bernie in 2020. Yes,
I acknowledged when Bernie no longer had a shot in
those campaigns and said, Well, I'm going to vote
for the best alternative of those who are left.
But I'm a Bernie supporter from 2016 and 2020.
I don't think Bernie should talk about running
in 2024. I don't even think Bernie should be
considering running in 2024, and I'm ready for
the hate. At this point, Bernie Sanders has become
a perennial candidate in the sense of the guy who
always runs and never wins. It doesn't mean he
never could have won or should have won, or that
it wouldn't have been a great president. I think
he would have. Bernie will be 83 years old in
2024. His term would start in 2025. He would be,
I don't remember what month he was
born in, but he would be 87 or 88
at the time that this Bernie Sanders term would
end. This just doesn't seem if you zoom out
big picture 30000 foot view like the direction
that the Democratic Party should go to say, OK,
we've had what we had in the last eight years.
We we have all the history that we've had.
Let's make our nominee after all of the criticisms
of wanting and needing someone younger than Biden.
Let's go with the 83 year old who lost twice.
It just doesn't seem like the way to go,
and I'm I'm willing to hear other arguments
and I'm ready for people to counsel me over
this. But it doesn't seem like the best thing for
the party. I don't really care about the party.
It also doesn't seem like the best thing for
the progressive movement, which I do care about
now. Who's better than Bernie? That's a separate
segment. We're not even through the midterms.
That's a that's a different conversation.
But it's time for a new generation to lead,
not someone even older than Biden who's lost
twice. And I hate to say it. These are tough.
This is a tough pill for me to swallow. But who's
not nearly as popular as looking at Twitter and
Reddit makes it seem that's the reality. I think
it's been enough, and quite frankly, I worry
that it could even start to border on embarrassing
and kind of a joke if Bernie runs again. I think
that there will be a lot of very unserious. This
is this is a joke type of reactions if Bernie runs
again in 2024. I don't question the genuine
desire of Bernie to do what he wants to do
and that he cares about the thing. I share
it. I'm aligned with him. I'm highly aligned.
I'm not speaking as an ideologue here. I'm
speaking as a strategist and thinking about
what makes the most sense from that perspective in
2024 with respect. This is my view. I don't hate
anybody, not attacking anybody. I just think this
is not the right way to go. So my thought would be
don't run in 2024. Bernie, I am ready. I
am so ready to hear your thoughts. Find me
on Twitter at David Pakman. Tell me whether
you agree or disagree. Any responses to this
that are toxic ad homonyms. Some will be
anti-Semitic, even though it's crazy. I'm
Jewish and Bernie's Jewish, but this is the
type of commentary that leads to anti-Semitic
replies from some in my party. It's all going
to go where it belongs. It into the trash, but
substantive replies I'm ready for.
Find me on Twitter at De Packman